alors c'est trop bien parce qu'il ya des
serviettes hygiéniques et non sans être
trop facile que ça pue prochaine on joue
on a pris un kit hygiène
on a defla pour la semaine c'est trop
bien parce que moi je me fall et légumes
qui affronte de bagdad
[Musique]
vous
on
à
c'est qu'on a mis parce que j'ai pas
fait de travailler c'était des blagues
au bide
bah du coup je vais revivre et de mes
dépenses des élus qui ne trouvent pas de
travail pendant ces moments passés
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'avoue que déjà je fais du baby sitting
pour pouvoir me permet de vivre un peu
parce que du coup mes parents ils m'ont
pas du tout donné dessous pour vivre ici
après une paye le loyer
donc c'est déjà ça mais il faut que je
me débrouille tout seul donc c'est vrai
que par le gab et de moments où j'étais
un peu en mode été offert mais bah du
coup ça c'est pratique parce que j'ai
bien une semaine sur deux les semaines
où j'ai vraiment baby sitting comme ça
ça me permet
[Musique]
paix à leurs âmes
ça par exemple c'est un plaqué encore
bon jusqu'au 1er février
donc c'est dans trois jours voilà c'est
un parmentier aux pleurotes fait maison
on a récupéré aujourd'hui voilà bah on
est très content de pouvoir le donner
ça vient
dans un colis alimentaire en plus des
pommes de terre des carottes de
souscrire à cuisiner ça c'est déjà après
un petit comique ondes et c'est bon
et
on a monté ce programme-là l'été dernier
pour préparer la rentrée universitaire
en disant il faudra quelques jours pour
les étudiants spécifiquement la
précarité étudiante elle a commencé avec
le continent
placer très largement aggravés et elle
s'est élargie à un public qui ne s'y
attendait pas
aujourd'hui nous qu'on voit c'est un
soutien fort des autorités locales et
l'état qui met du temps avec eux c'est
dommage
[Musique]
c'est pas possible que la question
alimentaire sont un succès pour les
étudiants c'est pas possible se pose la
question de se dire est ce que je fais
mes études je finis mes études
où est ce que je vais manger c'est pas
possible c'est pas normal et nous on
célèbre mais comme ça on est peut-être
un des derniers flexicurité qui restent
[Musique]